more recently i've been reading the
bible and praying which is not something
i was brought up to do at all and some
weird very strange things happened that
made me even with a more logical mind
question how i was thinking my mom had
cancer we went to a whole bunch of
different specialists all over north
america and they all said you have eight
and a half months to 11 months and
there's nothing you can do about it and
it was a very rare absurdly like you'd
see in the movie rare type of cancer
where it's like 30 people have had this
and they all die she had surgery and
then the surgery got botched and she got
injured that almost killed her and then
she became religious while in the
hospital on the verge of death she goes
oh i'm gonna be better by my anniversary
with jordan august 18th and we're like
okay and then she had to have another
surgery and then that surgery didn't
work three days after that surgery
everything just fixed itself and it was
august 18th my family we were just like
okay all the doctors had no idea why
things just resolved my mom was like
yeah i knew that was gonna happen she
says it was god after that i was like
okay that sounds pretty good whatever
happened there i'm a fan of